la ciencia no es para mujeres nunca
serás una buena científica de la ciencia
no se ve frases como ésta llegaron algún
momento en mi trayectoria académica y
profesional y estoy segura que muchas de
mis colegas han escuchado estas frases
en algún momento
sin embargo estos estereotipos que hay
sobre la mujer en la ciencia en el mundo
no detuvieron mis sueños que era
estudiar el cosmos recuerdo cuando era
niña viajaba durante las vacaciones a
manizales donde una tía y su esposo que
es matemático para hacer el viaje más
ameno mi tío como le llamo nos ponía
ejercicios matemáticos y en me encantaba
tanto fue el gusto por la matemática y
por estos juegos incluso en unas
vacaciones pasé resolviendo los
ejercicios del álgebra de baldor
ese gusto siguió y me llevó a estudiar
física en la universidad del valle en
donde recuerdo cuando una vez tomé un
curso optativo de astronomía y nos
llevaron a las canchas a observar por
primera vez mediante un telescopio ahí
observé a saturno y a sus anillos y la
vida me cambió en un dos por tres
en astronomía los referentes que siempre
se escuchan son nombres como carl sagan
albert einstein galileo galilei grandes
investigadores claramente pero que
incluso se acompañan o se unen un poco
de esa frase que les dije al comienzo la
ciencia no es cosa de mujeres lo
interesante de todo esto es que hoy en
día yo sé que eso no es así porque yo
soy una de ellas y lo mejor de todo esto
es que no estoy sola con el tiempo me
doy cuenta que son muchas las mujeres
que han estado en las ciencias en el
caso de la astronomía también no no hay
diferencia pero lo que pasa es que
muchas de ellas estuvieron una época en
donde el acceso a la ciencia y a la
educación para las mujeres era negado y
muchas veces tuvieron que publicar los
resultados de sus investigaciones
mediante sus representantes masculinos
hablamos de sus tutores o sus jefes
pero la astronomía hoy en día no es que
haya cambiado mucho el recuerdo cuando
entregas la maestría en méjico entre un
departamento de astronomía donde la
mayoría podría decir que incluso todos
eran hombres la mayoría de los
profesores y los investigadores y esto
me llevó otra vez a preguntarme será que
sí es cierto que la astronomía no es
cosa de mujeres y si no es así dónde
están pues resulta que según la unión
astronómica internacional solamente el
21 por ciento de el grupo de
investigadores a nivel mundial se
dedican que se dedican a la astronomía
son mujeres en el caso de colombia que
hace parte de esta organización
internacional solamente el 9 por ciento
pertenece o representa a mujeres y
estamos hablando de 33 mujeres
ahora en mi caso del ministerio de
ciencias nos dice que según las
las cifras para el 2017 solamente el 12
por ciento de los investigadores a nivel
nacional son mujeres que se están que
están investigando en ciencias físicas
entonces esto en un media o tres
afrontar me
por qué sucede esto ese escudo de género
eso fue una de las tantas preguntas que
un día decidimos reunirnos cuatro
mujeres colombianas que están haciendo
investigación en astro ciencias y
buscábamos resolver pero lo interesante
de esto es que estas cuatro mujeres no
estaban en colombia sino que estaban en
diferentes países países como suiza
mexico friends francia y alemania están
haciendo su maestría y su doctorado
realmente nosotros nos hemos conocido en
el exterior y eso pues muchas veces nos
lleva a pensar que éramos muy pocas las
mujeres colombianas que nos dedicamos a
esta área de las procedencias claramente
hemos escuchado referentes como adriano
campos la doctora adriana ocampo quien
trabaja en la nasa y esto a veces nos
preguntaba bueno será que es por eso que
hemos escuchado porque está en esta
organización internacional debo confesar
que el comienzo pensábamos que éramos
máximo 20 mujeres pero lo importante no
era el número sino buscar este grupo de
mujeres colombianas que estaban en esta
área y crear una red para generar esa
unión y que todos nos sintiéramos apoyar
la idea era que muchas cabezas pensaban
mejor que una sola y sobre todo en una
problemática como es el bajo número de
niñas y jóvenes en el área de destino
es así como surge chía colombianas
haciendo investigación en las
trescientas la idea de chía es
visibilizar el trabajo de investigación
de alta calidad que hacen las mujeres
colombianas aquí en colombia y en otros
países investigaciones incluso son
similares en cuestión de calidad
similares son mejores a muchos
referentes masculinos colombianos aquí
en colombia y en el exterior
para esto
y decidimos hacer uso de una herramienta
que hoy en día tienen acceso muchas
niñas y niños en colombia y en muchos
otros países y son las redes sociales
asíes usamos las redes sociales para
difundir las conferencias que hacen las
chinas como nos hacemos llamar pero no
solamente las conferencias sino también
compartimos los logros académicos
profesionales e incluso también
compartíamos sus perfiles para que
sirvan como es un modelo a seguir para
las nuevas generaciones de niñas y por
qué no también de niños y de jóvenes
colombianos
eso sí que es importante pues en muchas
ocasiones son de son indispensables
estos referentes para para que estos
niños y niñas tengan esas diferentes
opciones profesionales y puedan decidir
que lo que quieren estudiar o que
quieren ser en un futuro y no solamente
se limite a esas opciones que tal vez la
cultura les ha establecido
para nuestra alegría hoy con somos
alrededor de 60 chicas mujeres
colombianas que se dedican a hacer
investigación de alta calidad no
solamente aquí en colombia como ya lo
dije sino en otros países en diferentes
instituciones y en diferentes áreas de
la astronomía a nivel mundial como como
les mencioné
lo maravilloso de todo esto es ver como
cada una de ellas se ha apropiado de
chivas quienes participando en
diferentes espacios
y esto representándonos como comunidad
espacios como ciencia viral del
periódico 'el tiempo' en donde nos han
contactado en diferentes ocasiones para
hablarte de temas a nivel internacional
de mucho interés a nivel internacional
como por ejemplo cuando encontraron
fosfina en venus nos contactaron para
hacer un conversatorio acerca texto en
donde una colega
habló sobre esta investigación también
hemos participado en espacios como el
observatorio de la sergio arboleda en el
planetario de bogotá y en diferentes
escenarios a nivel nacional también
participamos en el campus para 2020
donde tuvimos por primera vez un panel
solamente de mujeres para hablar de
mujeres en la ciencia
también estuvimos en la semana mundial
del espacio evento organizado por la
comisión colombiana del espacio la
empresaria y otras organizaciones e
incluso participamos en la celebración
del día mundial del asteroide y otros
espacios en los que hemos participado de
igual forma hemos creado la red de
astros científicas colombianas esta red
es un grupo profesional donde lo que
hacemos es apoyarnos compartiendo
oportunidades de becas de intercambios
de conferencias congresos y muchas otras
cosas incluso también nos hemos unido
con la conexión que hay con otros grupos
como gam que es grupo de astronomía y
astrofísica macondo de aquí de la ciudad
de cali al cual pertenezco en donde
trabajamos por la equidad de género por
ejemplo este año hicimos parte de la
campaña internacional y nacional de la
búsqueda de asteroides
de la días que es una organización
basada con la nasa en donde incluimos un
estudiante de una institución aquí de
aquí de cali que trabajó arduamente
mostrando ese gran interés que tiene por
la astronomía en este caso y lo mejor de
todo esto es que mostró ese cómo
disfrutó esta experiencia
estas actividades se realizan en pro de
una sola cosa y es romper esa brecha de
género que hay en ciencias y sobre todo
en un país con tan poca tradición
científica para terminar quiero citar a
una frase que una vez una amiga me dijo
una amiga muy cercana y es no podemos
hacer lo que no vemos y esto sí que es
cierto en este caso ya es ese referente
que tal vez a mí ya mis colegas nos
hubiera gustado tener en algún momento
pero no importa lo importante es que ya
ya está aquí para apoyar a esa nueva
generación de niñas y jóvenes
colombianas que quieran explorar o que
sueñen con explorar el universo muchas
gracias